so how do we analyze the data because
sometimes you can get for example
contradicting results yes so um it's
highly you know UX people what they love
to answer you know that by now
it depends right so it highly depends on
the question that you're trying to
answer so if you're trying to answer a
question such as which design is better
design a or design B there's not a lot
of you know fancy analysis that goes
into that you have numbers that can
either show you that it's either a B or
a tie so the majority of people decide
um if if it's if it's such a question
that write a or B but a more complicated
question would be you know do I have a
good idea or not or you know what do
people need that's hard that's not the
majority sometimes I call these
headbangers when you see only one person
that does something or behaves in a
certain way you only need one person to
understand okay this is important I
don't care that the nine others didn't
demonstrate this behavior I know that
this is important so it's not easy it's
a team effort it's a team sport research
is never the researchers if you if your
startup is fancy enough to have a
researcher it's not their responsibility
it's it's a team sport so the data is
not going to be always very helpful so
what I like to do is have people in the
team be involved in that if you have an
engineer if you have a product manager
the entrepreneur himself or herself a
designer a marketing person whoever you
have have all of these people coming
from all of these angles observe the
same behavior and decide what's
important here together that's going to
be the way to analyze and synthesize the
data to decide together it's not always
clear it's not always easy I would say
this is the hardest part of research is
understanding okay
what is the result here what what did we
find out sometimes I use a tool that I
created I call it the the rainbow
spreadsheet so the rainbow spreadsheet
is a spreadsheet that allows you to list
all the observations everything that you
see all the behaviors that you see and
let's say you observe another maybe five
people six people and then you just
highlight or color different cells to
see which participants we call them
people we we invite to participate in
research demonstrated that that behavior
and then you get some kind of a
histogram of what what happened most
that's helpful in coming to conclusions
into you know what happened here and
what does it mean